Adam Carolla is an expert on the
hilarious and terrifying he joins us
tonight Adam Carla thanks so much for
coming out it's it does seem like the
standards for leadership have been
inverted like the craziest person the
least competent person the most
obviously unqualified person
becomes the leader of everybody else
well I mean think about this do a little
thought experiment all the people you
just mentioned and will throw in Biden
will throw in Kamala Harris as well
would you hire them to coach your small
town High School football team
and if the answer is no if you like you
literally start laughing right if you
said Feinstein or fetterman or even
Biden the Kamala Harris Pete budage any
of these people if you said I would like
them to coach our high school football
team you would be laughed out of the
small town you lived in so if they
cannot raise to that level then maybe
they shouldn't be running the government
but I think they're running the
government because of their deficiencies
so if you just took a cross-section of
10 000 people from the phone book
assuming phone books still exists which
they don't but it's a cross-section of
the population you would get some high
aptitude people some low aptitude people
this is not a representative sample like
the U.S Senate for example the White
House it's disproportionately stupid and
crazy like we're selecting bad people on
purpose
well it does dovetail nicely into the
sort of intersectionality and all the
woke stuff and all the affirmative
action hires but could it go any other
way
I mean if your criteria for hiring a
football coach was we need the gayest we
need the darkest we need the one suit
cross-dress and transgender how would
that football team's record be at the
end of three years of playing I mean how
else could this go
well maybe you've Hit Upon a solution to
the current crisis in our former
meritocracy where Congress passes the
law forcing the NBA and the NFL to abide
by the same hiring standards they're
imposing on say JP Morgan and Citibank
and everybody else why not do that and
we can all watch what happens when you
abandon the meritocracy
well it would be the greatest experiment
ever and I think it would be
very informative to a lot of people I
think if you said we're gonna do a
basketball team that's we're going to
hire by the same standards that the
federal government hires in terms of
intersectionality and race and
everything else and then you watched a
bunch of guys bounce the ball off of
their foreheads and into the first row
and score no points and each game would
end in a tie zero to zero then maybe
Americans would take a look at the
horrible sloppy play on the court and
say we don't want this in our government
the problem is is we can't do the math
we're not doing the math the second Joe
Biden said I'm gonna I'm gonna run with
a vice president who's female and black
another people should have been outraged
by that that's an insane statement it's
a racist statement it's an insulting
statement to everyone who's in the
country I told you when I was on your
show a couple of years ago I said Joe
Biden is essentially a drunken airline
pilot and we're all in the passenger
seats that's insane and it seems like an
extreme analogy but is it that much
different
well it was actually foreshadowing of
what we're seeing in America's airports
now with the new near-miss every week
thanks to
the equity hiring standards now being
imposed in the airlines um so you you
call that early Adam Carolla appreciate
it
thank you thanks Zucker subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight